Want to grow healthier crops and boost
your profits? Let's talk soil building.
Soil health is the foundation of a
successful harvest. When we nurture our
soil, we're investing in our crops
future. Start with cover crops. These
protect and enrich the soil. They add
organic matter and prevent erosion, too.
Next, consider crop rotation to break
pest cycles. This not only keeps your
soil fertile, but also improves
biodiversity.
Don't forget about adding compost. It's
like giving your soil a superfood boost.
And remember, soil testing is key.
Knowing what your soil needs is like
having a personal trainer for your
crops. Implement these practices and
watch your yield sore. Ready to
transform your farming? Let's dig in.